quel âge avez-vous 17 ans et vous êtes
dans premières
semblent attacher beaucoup d'importance
à votre coiffure oui aussi si justin que
la coiffure chez un garçon c'est parce
que toute sa personnalité
plus que dans ses vêtements nous on
évite moi aussi ont beaucoup
d'importance mais
la coiffure et de l'événement si la
personnalité d'un garçon est alors que
s'est il passé quand vous êtes arrivé au
collège a mauvaise foi oui on m'a
demandé de nous les cheveux parce qu'il
estimait je voulais chaud trop longue
je me suis laissé pousser les plantes
mais pourquoi justement avoir choisi
cette façon de porter les cheveux longs
est ce que c'est à peu près le seul
moyen qu'on a pour couvrir pour prouver
qu'on existe